hey guys welcome back to the world
podcast thanks again for tuning in to
another episode season two is starting
to come to an end but i do have some
unreal guests to finish this season so i
am really looking forward to that and
thanks to anyone who has shared a
podcast on social media or in person
throughout the year it is very much
appreciated and thank you very much for
anyone who has got themselves some
waterlab merch you guys are the real
leads for helping keep this podcast
going and if you do enjoy this podcast
and you are keen to support head over to
wallet.com where there's plenty of ways
where you can help this podcast anyway i
have a genuine superstar on for you
today so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today i'm lucky enough to be joined by a
man who has officially put up more fins
than anyone on this planet he is a
freakish talent and not many have made
international rugby look as easy as he
has he's obviously one of the great
tasman marco he's been a huge part of
the crusaders success and now he's
forced his way into the all blacks wing
spot with some unbelievable form
and as you all know he's on what lad
because he is one of the great lads it
is the man himself will jordan welcome
mate thanks for having me on julie
steering intro there um
i'll be looking forward to it on this uh
podcast for a while i've been
disappointed it's taking this long to
tear up so you were one of those guys i
was expecting to be able to get into the
studio i was hoping you're going to be
coming back to you know tasman or maybe
show your face now and again in the
nelson region but mate you've just blown
right up and you've you're gone for good
i don't think you'll be coming back here
for a long long time well i would do is
enjoy my time in nelson blenheim so yeah
fingers crossed i'll be able to get back
in the district at some point mate and
you have put up a thousand fins up
you're always ripping the tasman marco
even quinny's still into you about it
being too slow what what's that all
about
that was unbelievable from quinn strange
the feedback he was given here my fins
up um
although to be fair i got he would have
seen the video i got quite stuck into
him and i was questioning
whether or not hit it she would put her
fins up before in his life and then he
did actually score on the final and i
don't think i've ever seen one someone
put one up as quickly as he did
original thing it was like
it was obviously excited about it so
good to see the ford's getting stuck in
behind it too oh 100
and mate what are you up to at the
moment you're obviously in isolation how
are you how are you feeling your days
yeah it's been reasonably quiet in here
to be fair um
pretty big supporter of the nba so
sort of games to pop in about one
o'clock every day and go through to
about sort of five or six so
just kind of been
in the wreck watching those throughout
the day in the afternoons and
um obviously the black tips have started
up uh they're testing in india which has
been cool to watch as well matt you're
just some full-on sports mode
yeah absolutely
um obviously let's talk about the tour
um you're i know you're very astute
thinker of the game what what was your
take on the tour give us the rundown
from your point of view
yeah geez what part just summary of now
i think it was
um well obviously just personally for
myself it was cool to get away um
i taught you all this last year
be able to get but
again and
for me up to the northern hemisphere for
the first time um
playing the environments up there which
can be pretty daunting with the just how
vocal the crowds are and
even playing the springboards the first
time as well it was just cool to be able
to
get stuck into those environments and
i guess as a team um you know we had
plenty of time to get it on and off the
field and i think off the field
um yeah the connections really grew and
by the end of it um you know we're
getting on pretty well and because our
on-field performances i thought we
started really well and obviously those
last couple of games have left a
slight sound taste in their mouth for
the summer so
yeah a bit disappointing finish like
that and gives us a chance to have a
good thing over the summer and
have a good super next year hopefully
get another quick at the origin those
other teams what was your reflection on
those two games to finish what what'd
you guys talk about in your reviews and
stuff um
yeah game management was
a pretty big one particularly off the
back of that irish desk um
i guess as a team we haven't reviewed
the french game too much just because we
flew out so the next day but
exactly the irish game i thought the
irish were outstanding in that game like
they really like threw it at us i think
um what was 170 tickles or something in
that first half like we were
sort of holding on to dear life um
so i was just about like how can we hold
more ball and be more effective when
we've got it because any time you have
to make 170 seconds and a half then
and talk to me about the um france game
i know you guys won't mention it but a
nine o'clock kickoff is
crazy late to have the body ready for an
international test match oh so how did
you guys find that yeah it's interesting
like it's a pretty um
like it's a big day of code in the
northern hemisphere doing these awesome
tests like you've got test matches
kicking off from
like we played italy at two o'clock and
then um basically there's just big games
all the way through until
till nine so it is a bit different with
that late kickoff um
i mean i guess it's just a case of just
probably managing your sleep throughout
the day like i quite enjoy having a cap
on game day so i just made sure a couple
hours in the afternoon and that meant
that by about nine o'clock was i was
ready to go i think um
a few of the boys who are sort of early
birds and go to sleep early they were
sort of a little bit more effective but
um obviously being pretty light anyway
so it wasn't too much issue for me was
there anyone who stood out for you from
any of the teams that you played while
over there was there anyone you thought
man this this guy's good um
i thought like
from initially this when you ran out
against the south africans it was like
like that big boy is like a big dominant
pack and i thought well they affords
like um
and khaleesi like they were just yeah
physical specimens
um they with the first two and then
um
i'll give a shout out to another what a
lead it would be james lowe actually i
thought um in that game against
um
very well a lot like we know he can i
keep in new zealand
strings well yeah mate some some good
options yeah there's some quality
players around there i can't believe i'm
just giving a little shout out but
[Music]
he's coming on shortly too as well
actually he'll probably give you a shout
out too no doubt i don't know he's a
good lad
tough to get praise from there
but he was just stoked with his d-read
who was that on rico
his money just stopped hearing about
that in the media actually
oh no it's good to see him playing well
though and you obviously uh cemented
your uh wing spot um
do you still prefer fullback where do
you see yourself do you like 15 or
winger um yeah like i was pretty happy
just um on the wing for the abs this
year um
it was cool to sort of get
a good run of games and string a few
together and i think that helps
um rather than sort of playing one and
then you're in and out of the team so
that was cool and
i think for me like i haven't actually
played too much wing before so yeah just
like that continuity stuff it was cool
to be able to take some learnings from
game to game um in terms of the fallback
community wing stuff like it's
a bit so either all for me like like i
enjoyed playing fullback for the
crusaders and that's sort of where i
played was my footy but like yeah if
it's on the wing for the abs then um
that's happy days as well pretty good
running around
ball back especially at the moment so
let them get them jewelled out there
mate there's a heap of cattle everywhere
though in the outside backs and at 10 i
mean you and even the midfield as well
you guys are you guys are not short of
options in that back line at the moment
no i think it's particularly been the
beauty of the year we've had with having
such a big squad and having so many
games is that you know it's given a lot
of guys opportunities and i think
basically everyone who
went away on tour at some points put on
a pretty standard performance like um
obviously saw quinny and braids and the
midfield trick against usa we're pretty
strong and corny as well in that last
test and you know bridgey sivu
rico said a great year davey coming back
so like you say um yeah plenty of boys
putting their hands up and you're hoping
to be straight back at fullback for the
crusaders you mentioned there's some
quality outside backs down there as well
you've got um your servers your bridges
your davies and um lester obviously had
a huge season here for tasman as well to
add to that mix you've got in or you
guys are not short of backs down there
either yeah geez the combination doesn't
get any easier does it um
i like to find a new position i reckon
just outside back just keep popping up
everybody everywhere
a nightmare no it's um cool i think um
be able to repeat those guys over the
last couple of years who um we've always
had one or two guys injured so the last
few years with jack being out right and
being out bridgey being out um
it's sort of all managed to work out
they're like everyone's been able to get
out there but jeez i mean if the team
gets run up being injury-free then yeah
i'd hate to be razor trying to pick it
even like the young boys coming through
like shea had a good year for canterbury
i thought from what i saw he looked
pretty fast in that 15 jersey and uh
obviously kena hollow coming down from
the neck as well he was scoring twice
for fun so um
that'll certainly be a pretty
competitive unit down there next year
right you guys are stacked
obviously with the long tour and stuff
you obviously have to
find something to do in your spare time
and sounds like you guys were right into
your golf that was what you're living
for on tour oh it is the boys do um
enjoy their goal for sure there's a
pretty good group of us now like sort of
you're getting between three to four
full groups 12 to 16 guys
on the day off which is good we actually
had in our week off in new so we had
this like ryder cup format going so we
played three days straight the two
barretts as captains and um went right
at it so that was good fun but
um
yeah i mean some of the courses that
body was able to organize on the
northern tour were
pretty good going he's got a future in
um golf logistics i think but um yeah
the boys boys are hacking hacking around
some good courses it'll be nice if um
we're playing a bit better
and it's always enjoyable getting out
the day off and just being able to have
a bit of a hack and
like we take it reasonably seriously but
at the same time like if it doesn't go
too
too good
yeah and talk to me about the 18th hole
at la golf in france
um i've had this question sent in from
nagi so i'd love to hear what it's all
about
oh
um
me and jimmy kane have taken on throwing
balls me and sami kane taking on
nugget and geordie
and
to be fair we're probably
we're probably controlled most of the
match well it was pretty even but we
were sort of maybe
one or two up through about 15 and then
that's tightened up we've come down 18
and part five long story short
i've four part of the 18th green and
we've lost
i had like i had like a downhill four
footer for the win
it's all square coming down 18. like a
four foot down hello
and
i've taken about five minutes to read it
i could have sworn it was straight so i
just belted it
it's a mess which has left like an eight
foot on the way back for the half and i
missed it too
but it was funny because the hole was um
the hole was like surrounded by water so
as soon as i missed the other part i
just whacked my ball into the drink
and on that hole i'd actually put a ball
my approach shot into the green into the
water as well so i played eight on the
whole and body retaliation gone and
fished that ball out while i was putting
because i had finished so as i've walked
off the green he's throwing that to me
and well i wasn't interested in that so
i'll grab that and i'll just rip that
back in the drink as well
yeah i was so dumb
hey that's so unlike you
bottled it
i know
it was a shambles there's obviously some
good golfers in the group a it sounds
like jordy's playing off scratch and
we where do you fit on the rankings um
yeah i'm sort of probably mid tier like
i've
yeah i'd like to i'd like to be higher
than what i am but top five oh
i'll probably be about six oh yeah
yeah geordi like jordy shot 72 that
daily golf national um geordie body
damien
witty nugget that's pretty big on me
dave is david and i've usually pretty
similar he probably played a bit of me
on tour so
i might even be in the seventh slot
i'll tell you one guy right here
i don't know
one guy definitely better than is
antoinette brown though um
actually two guys were definitely what i
mean
[Laughter]
oh he would um
so no i think i think it'll be a big
summer for me actually just really like
to get into my work get down to the
range and get myself back down at that
top four or six next year it can be a
good goal for me for 2022.
nice goals what else have you got
planned for your break so when are you
back with the crusaders um not that till
sort of first week of february so gotta
go oh yeah decent great weeks off which
is nice um
yeah i'm actually doing a summer school
paper in here at the moment so that's
been a bit grim um nice what are you
doing just the economics paper i've got
about five papers getting my degree so
just trying to activate that and i
thought quarantine would be a good time
to chip away at it but
hopefully they won't take up too much my
summer it's done in a couple weeks so
that'll be good um yeah golf uh i've got
the black clash
in january the crew game which will be
good fun looking forward to that um
and yeah just catch like it's quite a
good time december just to catch up with
like schoolmates and
guys you don't see throughout the rest
of you that much when you're sort of
stuck in the funny bubbles so yeah good
to catch up with those boys what is that
black clash like what's that what's that
whole experience like is it a bit of a
joke around or is it pretty serious in
there um oh it's a good couple days like
um the night before they sort of have a
bit of an event and you know the voices
out for a few drinks and
those sort of guys that sort of almost
have a bit of the reunion throughout the
year there's some guys in there who
haven't seen each other for a while and
obviously for team maybe there's some
old faces as well so
firstly it's just probably quite a cool
couple days just networking and
having yarns of people from the two
different codes and
picking up hidden gems here and there um
in terms of the match like yeah like
you're playing pretty seriously you're
playing a win and going hard as you can
i think um
it's almost a bit of a tough matchup for
the rugby players so
i would imagine the career players at
times are probably holding back a little
bit um
yeah they probably definitely are but i
think there's rugby team
and you've carried that side last few
years haven't you too with your qriket
background you and jordy always the
standout top scorers guys will be
melting you up again this year
well i'm a bit concerned this year i
opened the bedding last year um
but this year i've heard that shane
bond's playing so i'm not sure
how quick he can bowl but
i'm not sure i want to find out so
yeah he looked hard to get away last
year for the boys he's on the field day
i didn't have to face him luckily but
yeah a few of the boys said he was just
like
i see the wizard he was just tough to
get away obviously you still got all the
tips and tricks i think probably as a
general rule like it's easier for those
spinners who are getting a little bit
older for them to come in and fold their
floor overs as opposed to
someone trying to get off the long run
um yeah when they get a bit older so
um yeah he's definitely one to avoid
nice and how's your body in general like
is it feeling good you've had a massive
year of code so is the body feeling good
have you got a few niggles that you need
to
sort out during yeah i guess there are a
few niggles that kind of yeah there are
a few niggles that sort of um
catch up to the end of the year i
actually tore my head in that last game
against france uh
yeah when rico was running away it sort
of yeah got a pretty good tug
so um yeah she came off early in that
game which was disappointing but my
hammy had actually been legally sort of
the whole year so
it was probably fortunate that i got
through that last game without having a
hiccup so um yeah that's probably the
main one the other stuff's like you just
got little sort of bumps and bruises
here that accumulate but um
yeah after the two months off they
usually sort of come right and
start the cycle all again always nice to
get those few months off to just get
that body back to
where it needs to be hey oh hugely i
think
particularly this time with what like my
hammy is probably a sort of
would have been like a six to eight week
injury if it was in season so they were
not very code so yeah good time i guess
for it to happen in the summer when i
can give it a
good rehab process and hopefully come
back and firing and what sort of
pre-season training have they got on you
guys since you you've got this break but
you also need to
once you're coming back to super rugby
you pretty much need to be ready to go
away so what's that sort of pre-season
training look like for you guys yeah
it's a bit of a balancing act like i
certainly found it
um like you say you come back into
pre-season you're pretty much like into
the comp straight away and yeah but i
found that my first time doing that uh
at the start of this year like it is a
bit of a different experience trying to
get back up to full speed with only like
a week or two of like team training so
it is definitely a bit of an art nailing
that summer stuff like it's just sort of
a mix of like you want to refresh but at
the same time you don't want to take too
many steps backwards so
i think like in december yeah you're so
looking to just turn the wheels over and
um
keep your conditioning up and a few gems
in there and then
i guess once you get into january and
you're getting closer and closer to your
return date then you try to simulate
the stuff by doing in presets a little
bit more and um yeah i guess wrap up the
running and
the speed work and a bit of contact that
sort of thing just so that you don't get
a fright when you hit into day one and
pre-season and come move the next day
right sounds like you nailed it i'm
looking forward to seeing you
firing on all cylinders at round one oh
i haven't done it yet so rest a touch
base
[Music]
but as always i always enjoy hearing how
superstars like you get to the top and
how it all starts for you so
give us a rundown on what your life
growing up in christchurch was like as
it were young fella um
i had a older brother and an older
sister so
um particularly my older brother i used
to
get pretty stuck in the backyard i used
to play
plenty of probably more crooked actually
but we're always a pretty competitive
duo and um
yeah enjoyed getting stuck in
i guess from a young age i was always
really like into my sport like like be
cricket running whatever it was like i
always was pretty caring and always like
enjoyed watching the all blacks and the
crusaders and stuff coming through and
yeah just went to local schools in the
area and i guess um like into
christchurch boys was was a big thing
for my rugby i guess really like it was
a school with a lot of rugby history and
a lot of all blacks that sort of thing
so
but at the same time when i was at
school i didn't really take footy too
seriously like i was
playing but never really thought of it
as a career or anything like i wasn't
going to the gym or doing any huge
amount of extra training and that sort
of thing like i just sort of
um i think i thought about school footy
was just playing with your mates like
you had a group of guys who
you sort of went right through school
with and all through the grades you're
playing with them so both cricket and
rugby those are the sort of two things i
really enjoyed at school was just having
that group of guys that i played with
for quite a long time and then yeah i
guess as i sort of left school um
i moved into the crusaders academy and
went to uni then
that was when things started to ramp up
from a footy point of view and headed up
to tessie and um i guess from there sort
of
you just go through sort of the pathways
and um it's been a go okay so far right
so humble you boom through those
pathways and look at you now right on
top of the game so but let's go back to
your school a little bit uh was it true
that you were playing half back like i
can't quite comprehend you at halfback
no i was very much distributed
when i was at school
when i was when i was when i was younger
um
i was playing it in the midfield but
then when i got into high school like i
was just really short like i just didn't
grow whatsoever i was obviously like
bloomer so like year 9 10 11 i was like
rather plus photo like quite short so
i sort of with that i started to move to
half back which was like actually quite
a good transition because
like it sort of meant that i still made
like the a-teams and stuff um at half
that grizz like in the midfielder on the
wing like i wouldn't have um and just
sort of kept me like involved in the
game for a few years i wasn't actually
enjoying my footy
like that much at the time and then sort
of like halfway through year 12 um
i had a bit of a growth spurt sort of
throughout that year and got a bit
faster and stuff and that's where i
played a couple of games on the wing
before the first 15 and then
yeah yesterday came around and i thought
oh dude i'll go full we could go and
since then it sort of stuck um
i did actually end up one game and
yesterday and i did go back to half back
um in the second half
we were playing roncalli or something
and yeah i was on the bench
and one of the half bits got injured so
i coached like i'll just
check you on a hard deck in the second
half just to sort of give the other half
back a bit of a break too because you've
been playing hit some minutes
and the whole first half on the bench
like because it in
yesterday like i didn't pass the ball
that was the last time i went in there
and
i haven't seen that since unfortunately
um nah nah you know you know i can leave
when i was playing it um i did you know
i used to just play it more legitimately
as a half-back ship than that yeah
pretty questionable right to left um
though
i'm a bit closer
oh i just throw over a seat to the
twelve
the back end of your christchurch boys
career you were you were an absolute gun
you obviously well you were the top try
scorer throughout the um uc competition
and mate you were there's some footage
on youtube of you absolutely ripping
some team up you were a gun yeah i guess
like what i sort of thought was
as my sort of physical attributes kind
of caught up like i got a bit bigger um
and i got a bit faster like when i was
younger and coming through the grades i
did used to just watch like heaps of
rugby like i was a real cody growing up
and i think like just from watching so
much rugby like i picked a few things up
like
i guess in terms of like understanding
of the game and like
technically in that so
i guess ethereum as i sort of want to
see got a bit bigger and got a bit
faster like that sort of
i guess merged with like the sort of
like knowledge i had for the game at the
time as sort of like still quite young i
think that sort of yeah sort of helped
me when i was a bit younger and it was
yeah a bit of a bonus just getting that
speed and stuff coming through but yeah
like i said i had a pretty good year in
year 13 but like i didn't make nz
schools or anything like that so um like
off the back of that year i sort of
still wasn't really thinking maybe it
was going to be a career or anything
like that probably wasn't until like the
next sort of year or two that that sort
of came into interplay did you ever have
a decision where it was rugby or cricket
because you're also a really good
cricketer too weren't you
not really to be fair um
coming through i sort of i was playing
red cricket as well like under 17s and
stuff we can't agree but i never really
sort of got like beyond that level like
i was ever really in the frame for
probably like a new zealand team or
anything like that and yeah like i just
sort of thought once i left school i
still oh yeah i didn't have as much
ambition to go play cricket like i had
really enjoyed playing at school with my
good group of mates and stuff but like
when i left school i sort of thought
yeah i'll just sort of leave it there
and um
yeah that was sort of it really wasn't
wasn't the case if i chose to
play footy and not cricket um i did have
my academy softball and during the
summer that would have made my cricket a
bit ugly but um
yeah i wouldn't have headed down the
professional field
correctly i don't think
true
mate you might get one if you keep
scoring runs in the black class
yeah i know i need to get the game
broadcast in india somehow
[Laughter]
how did you end up in tasman then how
did um canterbury let you slip yeah so
um off the back of the
underlying teens tournament i was
playing for kendra in my first year of
school i actually initially had an offer
from
the strong arm waikato to head up there
and play i guess like damien had just
made the all blacks so they're probably
thinking they were uh short of fullback
um so they put an offer in um
and then from there it was sort of a bit
it was an interesting process because
at the time
uh brad moore who is it now the all
black coach he was helping out with
the caleb 19s and he was a crusaders
coach at the time
and so i sort of met with him
and like the academy manager the
crusaders academy manager
and they sort of said well
we don't want you go to waikato for
kind of obvious reasons because it was
sort of some bad bad beer after like
damian and antoine those boys had all
left sort of christchurch did up there
so yeah at the time it was kind of like
well geez
um
and so they they basically said
canterbury's pretty full at the moment
uh we've got like johnny mcmuckel um
bridgey
they just signed josh mackay um it's
sort of a 10 outside back already
so they said we're pretty choker and we
don't really envision you playing like a
team for another
like at least a year maybe two yeah
whereas tasman they're a little bit like
from the outside backs and they needed a
full back and i guess from that like
sort of crusaders influence um
basically offered up a deal and for me
it was a bit of a no-brainer because
one
i was pretty keen to play minor team
kind of straight away um which tasman
would kind of offering up and and two
obviously with ringy being there um leon
mcdonald i thought that was a good
opportunity for me as a fallback to to
go learn off him so yeah i was pretty
happy to hit up to tessie and um i was
actually really stoked and yeah haven't
looked back really a great environment
out there and as you know and really
helped my game flourish i think
and and how was ringy to learn from no
he was good um
yeah i think he's a little bit on the
quieter side but he was awesome i think
just
what i learned off him was like
just really like in-game situations
understanding like how a game flows and
that sort of thing like it's hard to i
use that's one good thing about a coach
who's played the game is that they've
been in your shoes before so they sort
of know what it's all about so probably
more
technically rather than technically from
him like just putting him around
positioning and
um from full work how you can sort of
pop up in the game more because you do a
bit of a license on the field to kind of
roam around so
um just picking his brain on
little tips here and there that one was
certainly big things but went a long way
that was um yeah definitely helpful for
me particularly young
did you feel ready did you feel ready to
be playing at that level you obviously
wanted to be playing at that level did
you feel like you were you were good
enough at this stage
uh yeah i think
just prior to that my 10th season was
the um
under 20 world cup which i went away
with the under 20s and
we had a pretty strong team for that
ended up winning it
and i had a pretty good tournament for
them and that gave me a lot of
confidence
i guess that i was sort of ready to
even though under 20 is obviously age
group stuff we had a lot of good players
there to sort of play well and that was
that
gave me a lot of confidence
moving forward but like at the same time
going into minor team like you're never
really sure
how you're gonna sort of translate
there's definitely a lot of nerves those
first few games and stuff and yeah i
think what i had to get a lot of good
players around me like i've just talked
about already but he was on the left
wing and he was a really good
communicator um very helpful for a
fullback and
team on the right wing who i played a
lot with
um at the 20s guys like hunty
nank davies flirting around so
that definitely helped a lot just having
a bit of familiarity with those guys and
having a good group who just let you
play your own footy i think like at the
time we played and still do but because
you paid a pretty like attacking brand
of code and that sort of suited my game
and
then that yeah definitely helped me sort
of translate in
and you were rocking the head gear back
then too eh would you would you look to
bring that back yeah i didn't like my
debut season um but it was probably as a
result of my debut season where i got a
couple of decent shots
um
then in 2018 i thought that he'd get out
from out of 10. yeah i sort of cringe
with those videos
i sort of i've had a big layoff from
concussion and confidence was down a bit
so
i sort of walked the ledge just ripping
of extra um
i don't think it'll be making a comeback
but i guess it played an important role
in just getting me back out there and
um getting stuck in but no i wouldn't
expect to
to see it
[Music]
occasions
your first year
your first season with tasman was was
that good that you did get called into
the crusaders squad didn't yeah was it
wider squad or was it full squad to
start um no it was full squad but like i
say before i had some sort of concussion
problems so i didn't actually end up
playing that whole
super season i only really even started
training fully in sort of
march april so i was pretty
anti-climatic like i was pretty excited
off the bat you might have seen um
obviously it's been from christchurch it
was a you know childhood dream stuff
play for the crusaders so i was pretty
pumped up about it and then
ended up just
sitting on the sidelines feeling pretty
dusty for about eight months so
it was actually a bit of a grim start to
my sort of super stuff um
yeah it was pretty frustrating at the
time actually not been able to get on
and
there's a few question marks around like
how long that concussion stuff was going
to last for and help wasn't going to
have to play again so it was pretty
it was actually a real tough eight
months for me that first super year to
be fair yeah i bet i mean like you said
just being signed with your dream team
and first year in there and you can't
even show the boys what you've got you
just got to sit there on the sidelines
and well the concussion makes it even
worse because you've got no definitive
timeline when you're going to be back
and
no one can actually see that you're
injured so you're just sort of sitting
there questioning yourself aren't you
yeah that was it and like i was i felt
like a real fraud because
we had so many legends in the crusaders
at their time like
you know rito
obviously sammy is still there but
dagger crotch um toddy like oh we just
all these legends of the game
and i was just thinking
well that wasn't my fault obviously but
i'm just not a smoker just like
partnered up on the sidelines like not
doing anything yeah i was like geez
these boats give me thinking like who is
this young guy like is he gonna do a bit
of work or and i just felt i just felt
like
dusty that whole year like i just got
real out of it and stuff and they
actually ended up thinking it wasn't
really concussion it was more this issue
i had with like my inner ear that was
causing it so
that's why it actually took someone to
sort out was it took so long to diagnose
it as that so
once that diagnosis happened then i
actually became good pretty quickly but
it just took like
ages that happened so i wasn't really
doing the exercises and stuff to come
right back oh yeah you're like i say
yeah i just remember thinking like these
old guys must just think like
i'm just on a holiday here
so was that actually an air issue it
wasn't there was nothing to do with
concussion in the end now well i had i
did get a head knock initially but um
during that first night of 10 years but
then i sort of regrouped from there i
was able to always pass all the
concussion tests and stuff like the
cognitive testing
and that sort of thing i was getting
yeah i was passing them sweet and it was
all good but you know i was just like my
vision and stuff was just a bit like
foggy in there i just felt a bit sort of
spacey
so yeah that was it was sort of a little
bit confusing but once they sort of did
this testing it was sort of a mix to my
inner ear and like religion stuff once i
sort of worked that out it kind of
correlated with the fact that
like cognitively i was going on good it
was just more about sort of balance or
vision stuff so oh it's a bit of a weird
one to be honest like it's pretty it's a
bit of a
strange thing but
yeah it sort of came right and haven't
had too many problems with it since so
um touch wood
so you would have been looking forward
to getting back to tasman after that
frustrating season
and you went up there and carried the
side to their first ever premiership
yeah i was pretty cool that 2019 here um
i certainly didn't carry the team we had
plenty of
decent
it was a real cool year because
the couple years before that like 2017
2018 we played the final i made the
final made the semi in 2018
and like we had a really good team but
we just hadn't quite be able to get over
the hump in those big games and
i think those two years before that were
really key in us just growing as a group
and
understanding what it took to win those
big games um
and that sort of kind of
correlated in 2019 i was having such a
good year yeah the boys went unbeaten i
mean we had a pretty stick scored we had
like squid came back um geordie typhoo
was playing pears crocketty came back to
nelson
we had a real strong team but
yeah it was still a pretty impressive
effort for you know tessie to win the
title i thought considering that you
know seven or eight years ago they were
trying to boot us from the comp um
so it was an amazing turnaround and
there was a pretty special
thing to be able to bring that title
back to
nelson and blenheim and pretty special
do by the sounds of it from some of the
other lads and from all accounts you go
pretty well on it i was a good dude yeah
we got to celebrate these um
these occasions accordingly don't yeah
so
we gave it a good crack is it shifty
photos that are
i
out
there
would have been the tuesday maybe which
would have been day
what's that sort of day four
maybe wednesday morning day five um and
there's these photos and we're just
award ceremony on the nelson light
sticks
and it's in front of the city there's
like it sort of steps and it sort of
leads up to this courtyard for the
viewers at home and um
there's this photo of us walking down
the nelson main street for this like
parade and like the boys have all got
sunnies on like holding blue powerades
heads down
just you just were just in the headlock
for a bit
it was a good phone those few days
and then from that season the following
year you end up getting your all black
call up so
what's that like obviously it's a big
moment for every new zealand kid to get
that phone call or um however you heard
it how was your how was your one
yeah it was pretty epic actually um
like it was off as a day after that
north for south game which we sort of
knew would basically doubled as an all
black trial since the score was getting
that the next day sort of woke up that
morning you're kind of eagerly awaiting
either a call from gilbert or nokia to
say you've made it or a call from fozzy
to say you hit it so
and
obviously i hadn't been in the school
before so i know either their numbers
saved so
it's not like you sort of find rings and
you see who it is you're thinking oh
here we go yeah right you just see a
random number
please
yeah it was a cool it was cool just
firstly initially being named in the
squad but um yeah really kind of sunk in
how
awesome it was especially just when we
started training and being around the
group and
checking when you go around the
community like when we went to sort of
rural areas or i think we need to
whakatane for a campfire first year and
just seeing like
how excited everyone was about the all
blacks being there and um how
enthusiastic it was
pretty cool being a part of that and
just seeing yeah how much people cared
for the team and then obviously getting
on the field was yeah different as well
my first game went terribly actually i
got knocked out and we lost so it wasn't
a particularly memorable night but um
yeah just just the whole build-up of the
week and you know putting the black
jersey on and the hacker and all that
sort of thing it's um yeah it's cool
stuff yeah true that was against aussie
yeah you only lasted what was it under
five minutes was that oh yeah it would
have been
it would have been about three yeah
three to five minutes i reckon oh
yeah
and it was
the end of it and that was that was
actually pretty good like it's
like you say it's not really what you
want
you make your debut and um yeah you
really sort of get three minutes out yes
that was pretty gutting i of lucky that
on the last game of the tour against
argentina i got another run
um and then
okay in that game because it would have
been
a bit depressing if that was
the one the one gaming involved i got
for the year was just that gaming is
aussie
yeah
pretty pretty abruptly
yeah got it you mentioned that north
earth south game a little bit earlier as
well um being the trial and that was a
game where you really lit it up and
one of the biggest clutch moments you
jumping over your teammate mitch hunt
to win the match
oh talk me through that moment have you
have you given him a bit of banter about
that since uh uh as soon as time goes on
i give him a bit more advantage about it
sort of like when i saw it when i saw
him in the sheds after the game
and probably the coming sort of week or
two after that like i didn't really
give him too much thinking about it i
felt pretty bad actually no i didn't
feel bad you know
like
he is like obviously a really good bait
of mine yeah it was unfortunate that it
had been overhand would be a bit of a
supply of someone else
um
yeah certainly certainly as time's gone
on i've started to give a more stick
about it
and like when we get a criteria for new
year's with him and drummer and davey
and those sorts of boys like he talked
about stick for that yeah
but i think as aside from that and it
was just such a cool game like
i don't know if they can find any way to
get that game or even a wee series like
on the national calendar it'd be awesome
i reckon
i think everyone really seemed to kind
of buy into it and obviously the game
itself is really cool it's just a
showing there was no crowd because it
would have been a pretty cool atmosphere
if there had been yeah and it was a
perfect game to showcase today with the
match winning try like that it was an
awesome finish to the game so did you
call that um cross kick on hunty because
you saw him there and you knew you could
out jump him or did someone just kick
that no i think before that we'd hit
about three penalty advantages like
right in the attacking zone and i
had been calling for it before that just
obviously just knowing the physical
difference between me and until the
crosstalk would have been a good option
i like it didn't really get out there so
yeah i went me and jordy we didn't talk
to joshua as a team and just see like we
get the advantage again just just pull
trigger on it and just kick it um
and to be fair it was on the money scene
from george he was under quite a bit of
pressure
they came quite hard at him and he's
needed very well to execute that um
and put it put it on
so what has been the hardest thing going
into an all black environment what's the
what's the biggest difference from being
in a super environment to now being an
all black yeah it's a good question i
think
initially getting into the squad like oh
it's quite
like you might say is it quite daunting
and you're sort of you're sort of
worried it's going to be really tense
and
a really serious environment and you
have to be like on your toes the whole
time though
there was probably one thing that i was
like pleasantly surprised about
obviously like it was a very serious
environment and like when we were
on training and stuff like there's real
high standards that sort of thing but in
terms of like all the lads in the group
like it was pretty easy to get along
with everyone like it wasn't
there's obviously a hierarchy of respect
and that sort of thing but like after a
few weeks just sort of felt comfortable
you know i'm going to banter back and
forth that sort of thing so there was
one thing i did enjoy was
actually after a few weeks not feeling
like you're working on these shelves and
just being able to kind of be yourself
and i think that's been a bit of a
change relax i've had
what i gather over the last five or six
years is that idea of just being able to
be yourself and be who you are then
that's how guys you come into the team
be able to express themselves and play
well um i think yeah one thing i learned
this year in terms of the on-field stuff
is just how important it is to be on
for like every game which seems like
obvious but within a tour
or a
you know 15 game season like it is
it does happen we're mentally you're not
you're drifting and out of games or you
know your monty's like right that sort
of thing and that was probably something
i noticed that so the freaking game i
didn't have the best game i wasn't like
i wasn't prepared for the game i wasn't
like mentally up for it but
like it was just a
good lesson for me and how important it
is to just nail your prep every week and
just like really physically be up for
the challenge like
then it's picking up test 40 as like if
you're not physically up for it then
like you get found out so yeah those are
the two things i really took out of it
was just kind of be yourself and nothing
was just making sure week to week that
you're extremely diligent and
nailing your prep so when you go out
there you're ready to go and put your
best foot forward yeah mate that mental
part of it what you speak about about
not drifting in out of games is massive
they're the good players the great
players are so good at mentally staying
in the game for that whole 80 minutes
and it's a lot harder to do than you
think where a lot of guys especially as
you come down the levels will be in the
moment when they're around the ball and
then
when when they're off it they'll drift
and drift for just a few seconds which
will end up being the difference between
you know making the next play or not
yeah i think that's something i've not
struggled with but i've had to come to
terms with a little bit more play on the
wing this year as opposed to full work
whereas yeah
like get full work yeah just in the game
a bit more just because you're you're
closer on the field ball's getting
kicked you a lot and that sort of thing
whereas
like there were games this year where in
the first half like i barely touched a
nap and like i wouldn't even go my way
on d and that sort of thing like there's
a couple games i come in the [ __ ]
i think it's particularly important if
you have had a quiet sort of 5-10
minutes to like say mentally stay on so
that when you do get your opportunity
then like you're ready to take it
because yeah often do you see a team
finally gets the ball and then you know
they'll drop it straight away and that
sort of thing so
um
yeah particularly on the way that's
something i've had to really be aware of
right you're right on love it
another thing about becoming an all
black is obviously the extra attention
you get from fans and public and all
sorts so how have you found dealing with
that obviously everyone will be coming
up to you you're you're a good looking
man and everyone loves a try score i
hope which you score plenty so you
obviously get a heap of attention from
the public and i'm sure women as well
um
oh yeah i mean yeah yeah i guess there's
a bit more
sort of
yeah
and stuff like i don't know it's sort of
weird to think like i don't really sort
of like you know walk around town and
i'm not signing signatures every
um you know five seconds or i have to
have to put my hood up or put sunglasses
on all that sort of thing to
avoid getting seen not like bloody
lebron or christian or anything like
that but
um oh yeah just a little bit i think but
the scrutiny thing is something you do
have to
have to be aware of in terms of like
pretty mental space like
i think i've been reasonably fortunate
so far my career like most of the sort
of
media or
um sort of comments or like public
perception has been like recently
positive whereas
there have been a few games or a few
moments where it has been a bit negative
and like it is pretty easy to see then
and get quite caught up in it like
remember one game i played for tesla
like early in my career things been
going pretty well i had a real pool game
and like went online and i was just
seeing comments you're just like getting
sprayed and abused
and like seeing that for the first time
like it does actually
like it does throw you a little bit
i think i was like 19 at the time so
that's something that you've got to deal
with i think as you
along here and around the game like you
you hit your set and you just
sort of go to deal with it and you get
better at like filtering it out and
i guess understanding
whose views are sort of important and
that sort of thing so yeah it does
definitely have good and good and bad
aspects of it
so what would your recommendation be for
young guys who are you know just coming
through the scenes and they've had a bad
game getting sprayed on social media
what advice would you give them to cope
with that i think like the most obvious
advice there is is like obviously don't
try not to read it or see it but that's
quite often
not that easy if you're getting harder
through social media and it's right
there like it's
it's almost slightly unrealistic to not
see it because it's just it's so
accessible so i think the big thing for
me is i try to have like someone in your
team or in your environment who's like
opinion you really
kind of respect that he can have like
good conversations with the game about
so like for me like i'll do my own
review and that sort of thing and i'll
ever think about how i've played but
then like in the crusaders for example
i'll use goodies there like i'll go and
have a chat to goodie and i know like
we'll be able to have a good yarn around
how i've played and if i've generally
hit a pool game then he'll sort of let
me know and that'll be fair enough for
us if there's a few things that have
happened here or there then we'll just
look at how we can improve on that
rather than
getting too sort of like despondent
about it so i think that's important
rather than reading the
views of 100 people and one person might
think you've had a shocker in in reality
that's not necessarily the case so
that's probably the one thing i like
having is just having that one person or
two people whose opinions you trust you
can add to them and know you'll get like
yeah genuine feedback great advice like
that so going forward what's your plans
you've obviously got the crusaders next
how many years have you signed with new
zealand rugby um a crusader for life um
yeah at this stage i'm just signed up to
um yeah if you says
engine maybe through till uh end of next
year yeah um yeah i guess that sort of
process is starting to kind of happen
around
um looking a bit further certainly
enjoyed my time um and the black jersey
and the crusaders and tezi as well so
yeah i'd say i won't be going too far
and yeah i can't imagine i'll be
stopping my franchise anytime soon
either so um yeah fingers crossed it'll
get sorted and the next few years will
be hanging around is it true you came
quite close to signing with the
highlanders or highlanders made a pretty
big attempt to try and get you down
there um
yeah a couple of times like both times
i've sort of signed uh in 2017 and 2019
um i've had a few conversations with the
hollanders and at the time those were i
guess somewhat tempting because
like you say there was a huge long term
of players of the crusaders and i was
sort of like in 2019 i think
i played like nine or ten games half off
the bench half starting a few times i
wasn't even in the 23 and that sort of
thing so
the opportunity down to the hollanders
and whilst game time wasn't promised
like there was
a bit more of an opening there fall back
after binder was going to leave
the opportunity to play week in week out
was pretty enticing i had to kind of
weigh up
whether i wanted to do that or whether i
wanted to stick down the crusaders a
team that obviously meant a bit to me
and i'd learned quite a bit off from my
first two years
yeah it was tough but then and then i
decided that um i was better off
sticking around here and sort of felt
like
the competition of the group was gonna
bring the best out of me and i think
yeah i'm glad i made that decision i
think it's um that's sort of yeah if we
proved to be the case
100 did you are you looking overseas at
some point
looking to chase one of these um we
sabbaticals that the barretts and
mckenzies are taking at the moment would
you like one of those there's a bit of
left for me
overseas
like at some point
at some point in my career
i'll be keen to
to go explore that um whether it's
you know japan or europe i think one
thing that is actually enticing for
players is potentially like american
league sparking up like yeah i've been
to the states a couple times and if that
lead giver did take off in opportunity
to go a little over in the states for a
year or two would be
so i'll be pretty interested in so
it's moment it's sort of more it's kind
of minus pages but
uh if that did pick up i'd be interested
in that but
yeah i think at some point yeah i'll
jump overseas probably a few years down
the track and and give it a nudge
because you love your american sports
too don't yeah so you'd be right in your
element yeah i wonder why i have to try
to shift to a running back or a wide
receiver or something maybe
it wouldn't last last one um one down
and and then you fell but
like i say it's um like those those
american events over there just next
level like
the sheer amount of sport on and the way
they do it with
all the entertainment and stuff's pretty
cool so opportunity to get stuck down
there get down to the nba games nfl
games that sort of thing would be epic
have you ever looked at a or thought
about a um code change you talk about
nfl the eric and you'd be you'd be a
great running back but um nrl anything
like that have you ever thought about
potentially ever doing a switch like
that um i have thought about chasing the
pga tour dream before
no
a serious change um not really like
like i watched the the narrow a little
bit but yeah growing up i never played
league or anything like that like it's
not
that big in the south island or or
christchurch probably as much as it is
up north um yeah so yeah i never really
played league and
like growing up i watched the warriors
play a bit and stuff i watched nrl kind
of potentially a bit now but
uh there's never something that's kind
of been popping up from here already
been touched with thought yeah the one
sport actually i would i would like to
the hubby came to go do like a week of
pre-season or
just get into the environment would be
afl actually i've always found that a
cool game to watch
and i think a lot of the stuff they do
obviously on the ticking and
like the hybrid work and that would be
having quite a bit of correlation for a
battery player
similarities between there and and
players in the back three or playing
team just for a pre-season or would you
be keen to do a season ah
like
oh yeah i don't know i don't know if it
like it would ever actually happen
getting the uh season over it could be a
pretty big plunge
i mean michael hunt had it gave it a
crack okay and
i've done that i've done the three p the
union league afl um
i wouldn't say i wouldn't say that
something that would realistically
happen but yeah
like say the opportunity to just maybe
just for like a week or two go and train
with them and that sort of thing would
be something that would be fun but yeah
i do actually seriously enjoy watching i
feel like it's cool sport right that's
good stuff
and you've spoken a little bit about
your you being an economics wizard so is
that what your plan is after 40 ah
my degree is more sort of in management
i do economic degree it's more in
management
than economics so this sort of the
summer school papers were a bit limited
so i had to take one of these off but
um i actually started off first when i
was at uni doing law um and that proved
a little bit difficult
when i was playing footy to deal with
the readings and stuff for that so i
moved to commerce i've got about five
papers left so
i'm sort of just really hanging in there
the temptation to
to put on hold and just sort of do the
footy stuffs um pretty high but i'm
i'm probably far enough down the track
that i'm holding on yeah
like yeah i don't know necessarily how
much like i have learned some good stuff
throughout my degree and that sort of
thing i don't know if i have a long
footy career
i don't know if i'll necessarily like
use that to hit into a field but like a
lot of stuff millionaire manager
management's pretty just sort of
basic my life um just understanding
people and interactions that sort of
thing so
hopefully some of it correlates but um
yeah like i'm saying i'm just so close
now that it'll be
hopefully nice just to get the piece of
paper and it'll be something that
i guess i can be proud of managing the
two between my career yeah what is the
dream job for you post footy can't be
golf i know it's probably golf but
um
uh player agency is something that i've
always had a little bit of interest in
uh
i guess i'm coming from that lower
background like sort of yeah there's a
few correlations with that um that's
probably the one thing that i've had a
bit of an idea around maybe something i
could do but i think the stage is pretty
early days
it kind of depends on how my career goes
for and
you never know where you might end up
when these things happen i coach me
maybe but yeah i'm not sure you'd be a
great coach or a great player agent like
those two okay so i have to use a
reference
yeah anytime that you're an astute
thinker of the game
anyway mate as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and
you have come up with plenty
and a lot of them like i've mentioned in
the podcast a lot of them were from
um women who just wanted to tell you how
beautiful you are and things like that
so it's interesting to get you know some
with a bit of sex appeal on the podcast
which obviously hasn't happened too much
because this is the first time i've had
so many questions like that
but a couple of the lads have come up
trump's here too so uh
first question was from davey harville
one of the greats can he tell us how he
got the nickname glow on that's a good
question actually um
yeah well yeah it's reasonably sort of
expensive but basically last year we um
we had a buy in the rugby championship
last year so
we headed down to the local ordering
hole down in manly and
we had like a 10 o'clock curfew so we're
just sitting down for a few years but
yeah i guess we got through probably
five or six beers and
as you do start to get a bit of a tipsy
and get a bit of a glow on so
i'm
very just walking back and i carry one
he just started calling me up and from
there
is that your nickname now glow on yeah
that's pretty much what yeah most of the
boys in the team would win yeah
what about the coaches because that's
when you know a nickname becomes
official when the coach calls you it um
no the coaches haven't quite got there
yet
what do they call you what's it what's
their nickname they run they reckon we
will or just yeah jill used to be the
old one oh i still hear that around a
little bit yeah yeah jill and bill yeah
okay next one who is the hardest player
in the world to mark
not another shout out to you
tasman marco james
he's never going to have the pace yes
yes he's just stopping from the side so
if i'm playing jono in the future
um
oh there's a few like i think um
uh someone like mariki kara beach is
quite tough because he's
like he's he's quite small
like he looks sort of quite small and
he's quite fast and like
um athletic in that but then like he's
just a real like solid unit like
so you're sitting on that power game as
well which makes it quite tough like you
you got to sort of consider a few
different options you're still holding a
personal 10 minute knockout
yeah
if you're trying to take them with your
feet then that doesn't go well either so
um advice for home check with your
shoulders
um someone who i haven't really hit to
mark too much in games um and so break
me but i have streamed with the training
a few times
as actually rico because
like i'm saying with j.lo like a lot of
guys
i'll just try tend when i'm at full
weight to give the outside and i'll just
bet my speed to
be able to chop him down yeah he's
probably like the one guy well maybe not
the one guy but one of the few guys who
has probably got me for speed so i've
sort of
i'm cautiously getting the outside and
that sort of opens me up both ways so
he has he has got me a couple times at
training so he's one i've gotta gotta
work out but yeah on the international
scene um yeah corrabidi is pretty tough
i haven't had to play chisel and colby
yet but he's probably not yet
one-on-one
dangerous feat but it's interesting to
hear that you even say that rico's
probably got you on the outside as well
uh
damien mentioned he would be the
quickest in the all blacks where
a lot of people's perception is that you
would be the fastest in the all blacks
so when you're out on the field you look
you look super quick you make everyone
else look slow so
um
what's that about rico that makes him so
fast um
first i'm gonna blow the pit with damon
actually i was listening to that podcast
yesterday and you were talking the way
you stuff it around who was the fastest
and he didn't actually mention me and i
think the top five names he threw out
there so
i might have to
challenge him sprint because he doesn't
write me disappointed
he's just got he's got obviously the
build through he's got a big lot of
reckon between him and i i think if we
just lined up on like uh
i don't know if i wonder if there's a
difference between like in-game speed
and like genuine like sprinting speed
yeah i think maybe sometimes like
in my support playing stuff like
sometimes i i think i strength of mine
is very like sort of anticipate the play
so i think sometimes i look like i'm
running real fast
just because i've
compared to everyone else i might be
running just a little bit quicker
because i
sort of
yeah i don't know that's probably one
thing i have thought of in the past
because
i think definitely rico
um
in terms of kilometers and stuff would
be quicker than me yeah yeah well that's
what people said like people say in
times and stuff you're not one of the
fastest on your speed times and stuff
but when you watch you on the field mate
you look the fastest so like you say
things like anticipation being able to
carry the ball uh you seem to be able to
run the same speed while carrying the
ball and pretty much two hands as you as
you could probably in on the sprint
track so all these little things add up
and mate when you've got that ball
you're you're gone yeah i do a lot of
lawyers take the piss out of me for i
always run with the ball and two hands
we got a lot of questions about your
speed as well so um
and then pretty much the common one is
how do you train your speed obviously
body gave away his secret on his episode
his six week program what's what's your
what's your secret to him being so fast
um
yeah i think to be honest like speed um
in terms of like speed drills and
coaching and stuff is actually something
i'm keen to explore a little bit more
like i do
a few basic things but
i've never really done any like really
intense kind of work with like a speed
coach or
like really down like a big summer of
drilling in there so
that's something i'm looking forward to
doing but i think
it's got one of the big things one is
just having like a good like lower body
like strength like load like
i think like the stronger you can get
like in terms of your squat and your
hemis like your calf raises and stuff
like that's pretty important to
to running fast so that's like something
i sort of tried to do even though i
might not necessarily love the gym that
much awesome and then
i guess yeah in terms of that in terms
of their on-field stuff but i think a
lot of it like if you want to be fast
like on the field a lot of that stuff
around like
more reaction and agility and things
more important because
it's not that often that you're going to
really wind up the top gear and
you know at your max speed a lot of it's
around like
probably
5 to 15 meter efforts and
i guess being faster in that space
there's a big difference between like
making a line break and getting caught
like it's a pretty small kind of thing
so
any kind of like agility drills you can
do which is around like
quick changes of direction
or even any games where like you're
reacting to something happening and then
having to like sprint off there if that
makes sense
i think will help correlate speed off
the field kind of translate into
like on the field and performance yeah
and when you talked about your uh coming
through the grades as a young fella you
talked about your growth spurt and just
becoming faster that did that just
happen naturally that um speed that you
got yeah i think so like
i was reasonably fast when i was really
young and then when i had that
period of being to the mature side um
i slowed down a bit
and then and as i got taller
yeah the speed did just sort of come
back
and then i think definitely over the
last probably a year or two
i've got a bit quicker as i've started
to take gym a bit more seriously and got
a bit stronger definitely that somehow
thing is helped
interesting okay next question is from
uh hunty actually how come you haven't
had any success in the still golf day
yet
this is something that does haunt me
actually we have a um
there's a lot of a lot of stories i hear
about why golf just been disappointing
actually and it's
it's probably probably is unfortunately
painting a true reflection it's not
upsetting
realization i'm not as good
and we play this
this one-off golf day nine holes for
these jackets me and my partner this guy
from nelson ollie jones ellen
we haven't heard much like it actually
it's been
either two or three years now and every
other team
apart from us has won i think last year
drumming and quinn strange one
day of the year before so yeah there's a
lot of pressure on us this year to
deliver and given the fact that i've
four potted
agreed to lose a match about a week ago
it's
telling you my appreciation needs a bit
of work so that's definitely a reminder
to probably get my putter out my room
and just start
yeah
oh that's good stuff well that goes on
to the next one who is better for a
night out finn christie or david
harvelli
um
it's definitely dave because like
read read can go all night but like
you're going out with red he's just
gonna be an absolute piss the whole
night and he's just guaranteed to do
something something to it's just going
to piss you off like
he's just
he's just got that personality or he
just can't help himself so
like in terms of in terms of he can go
harder like they're both you know pretty
available for it but if you're going out
with reed you need to keep
eyes in the back of your head because at
some point it's going to come from here
i mean haven't even black here on this
tour honestly just being
you've never met a juror like it
two just unique individuals
oh a couple of lads
i do enjoy having a few bits of it i've
probably been able to ask there but um
yeah i'm gonna give davey the nod
yeah give it to skip okay next one um
why have all black wingers had such a
high turnover rate and how are you going
to stop that so that's interesting once
sort of around i guess what you talked
about about that pre-season and not
really getting that pre-season how you
managed to come back into it personally
i thought you were many like turnover
raters and like when we're
[Laughter]
no i think like yeah it is an
interesting one i think
obviously the outside back is a position
that is a little bit reliant on
athleticism in a way like speed and
agility and that sort of thing so it
does seem to be as you get older like
like props can sort of play through that
sort of 35 and still be pretty effective
whereas yeah
outside
27 28 probably
starting to decline and i think
um one thing you got to get being smooth
credit for is
the way he was able to keep playing
and be effective feel back actually was
about 33 so
um i guess that's kind of the blueprint
for it um around
staying in the game in the background
for as long as possible so i
might might give him a call at some
point and ask for the secret but um
the other thing is that you just see
across the country there's so many good
wingers coming through like yeah like
you say like even just the crusaders
next year there's like
seven or eight well six or seven guys
who could easily play on the wing for
the all blacks and it's the same across
all the franchises really like you look
at this year
even lester um and john and ricky were
two guys who were just carving up super
rugby yeah you'd think it'd be an all
black frame
and didn't make it obviously
like that she actually was playing seven
so
there's just a sheer number of guys who
are putting their hands up and i think
as a result you do just see a bit of a
bit of a turnover when you do get to
27ish will you start thinking maybe
moving back into the night
they want me to the late career
to keep me going
davey's i was actually talking to davey
about this because
he's oh he's not that old yeah dave is
what he must be 26.
and so he was saying he's kind of done
that sort of age grade shift into the
midfield which potentially could
keep him going for a few years so
i know i might have to start working on
my
life
i'm too tall for her feet now
i've been kicking i've been kicking a
few goals all blacks training just in my
spare time
yeah on tour so just just just casually
not as a real legitimate option but um
but maybe i'll make it where you move
into team could be nicer
[Music]
could we see a few goals from you and
that i'm super ugly this year kicking
goals
oh i think if we see appeal if the
crusaders get a penalty probably 65 out
then
you can probably expect more a lot to
the point of a place for me to get the
team
but i'm not you know if i'm kicking five
goals around the paddock probably you
know three yard over oh yeah not two
year four or five um
and yeah probably about 55 would be my
range so i don't have like a
don't have a torpedo like some other
boys so
it's gonna be a while before i get a
cake probably take like a kick off or
something before i'm getting a shotgun
that's a shame for the fantasy rugby
players because i don't know if you know
but you probably do but you are a
fantasy rugby wizard at um super rugby
level always leading the line breaks um
tackle breaks that's those sort of stats
so
um if you added goal kicking to your
string oh mate that would just be you'd
be the first million dollar player yeah
one thing uh andrew goodman can can
vouch for is that i am a gun from the
left-hand line
there's the one spot that i am
incredible from and that's because it's
right by the changing shoot at the
crusaders so i won't actually do a
goalkeeping system as i'm on the way to
the sheet i'll just quickly grab
someone's team just have a shot from
there i won't ever really hit him front
i'd love to see that on a match one of
that be good stuff okay next one
this one's from steffi actually are you
tired of getting the all blacks out of
your [ __ ] with your individual
brilliance
um
oh
no i'd be honest there haven't been too
many too many times where um the boys
have been down to be fair like
most time i've been playing i've just
been getting on the into the gravy train
and and putting them down i think
damien mckenzie in particular he's
getting sucker just putting
balls out on my chest want me to shorten
the line of me having to run around here
he deserves
[Music]
like if you're not screwing tries then
it's sort of a bit of an issue so um
yeah are you certainly doing that mate
okay next question hardest team to beat
at the 2023 rugby world cup in your
opinion
um
yeah there's a couple of teams that
stand out i think um
obviously the africans are a team that
like historically have been a big rival
for us and
they just played such a unique game with
that kicking game that i think yeah you
can see from any team they've played
this year like it's just that's a tough
team to beat because
because they're not playing with the
ball much like they basically just
playing that pressure game unfortunately
keeps a mistake so
like they're a hard team to kind of run
away from just just from the way they
play um so they're always gonna be a
tough game um
obviously ireland i thought were very
impressive when we played them um
yeah they they've had some great way to
be in that game
it's going to be tough and then lastly
the french with it being on the other
soil a young group as well so they're
going to probably grow over the next
couple of years
and certainly on the weekend when um
they had some momentum you know the
france with
i think 82 000 french behind them it's a
pretty yeah it's a pretty fizzing
atmosphere and um you know it's a it
sort of all goes so
i think we're playing them the first
game in the world cups against them at
that stadium so
um that'd be one if you wanted to go
with your game of footy i'd imagine that
would be
uh right up there that's the one to lock
in and hopefully you're on the wing
running out with the lads
fingers crossed two more questions um
what's it like being the sexiest man on
the planet
questions like these came in a lot like
i sort of mentioned before but jeez
you've got a lot of women followers fans
[Music]
well i am pleased those sorts of
comments coming in because obviously um
during super breaky this year i got the
real good um boot across the face
and got the decent a decent scar
across the cheek so i think i was a bit
worried that
they might had a big
impairment on my looks so
um
although it is a slightly more feedback
um
it's good to know that he hasn't
solved the deception too much
would you like to get into modelling or
anything like that
no i don't think so richie's doing some
good stuff with his um denim jacket and
top off and
obviously damien was pretty keen to get
nude for the week calendar so what about
you
yeah oh
that's probably not something i'm i'm
not
not too comfortable with your bottling
shoes it's bad enough for you
yeah your kitty and your sky shoots for
promo day so
like to leave that up to those lads
jamie and richie they look very
comfortable behind the camera don't they
julia i've seen his helen shoots going
around he's a natural so yeah there's
enough
there's enough bodies in that space in
new zealand mate the modeling
competitions as much as the outside
backs at the moment you guys are all
live
you're crazy okay last question
advice for a young player
yeah good question i think like the
pathway i've
always followed with my foot i think
that's just the way it's like i've just
always
really enjoyed the game like
i just starting from i didn't really
i wasn't really necessarily strong to be
a professional overplay i just sort of
enjoyed playing footy and
um there and just having a good time
with my mates has been something that
i tried to always sort of hold true and
i think when you're enjoying your footy
and
you're playing with a good bunch of guys
that's when you're playing your best
buddy and
like for example i look back on that
talked about a little bit in the podcast
around there tasman title in 2019
like it's the guys that we did it with
that i think about rather than the
actual win like i was like auntie reeds
um you know queenie davey
nancy or somebody ellie those guys who
i've sort of been real close mates with
and being able to celebrate with them is
the thing that i can remember from it so
that's what i take out of it is like
there's always you know working hard and
that sort of thing is obviously very
important um and a huge part of
being a professional sportsman but
honestly for me if you're not enjoying
it um you're not in an environment and
around people that
you want to be in then it's pretty tough
to be successful so um
that's that's the one thing i can't take
out of it i absolutely nailed it like i
knew you would hey always come up chance
with advice
well absolute pleasure having you on the
podcast mate um you're an absolute
legend like i said watching watching you
play as
you're one of those guys who everyone
gets out of the seat when you got the
ball and watching you come through the
ranks from tasman is probably what i
first noticed yeah and then going
through the grades to now being uh you
know the cemented all black wing has
been awesome to watch and obviously hear
a lot of stories about what you added to
the group here in tasman and you've been
a big part of this side's
with not only on the field but in the
culture as well so
it's awesome having you on the podcast
uh sorry it's taking so long and sorry
it's had to be via um online but mate
great to finally get it done no thanks
jimmy's been great to finally join the
club of elite athletes and leads who
have been on the bodies so um no it's
been awesome and hopefully someday i can
get in studio and do the fit face to
face oh mate can't wait appreciate it
mate you're a legend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you